[Music]
this morning on the dishes chef and
author who's brought the best of his
hometown to the nation
David woz was born and raised in New
Orleans and started cooking Louisiana
specialties as a teen he started his
career as a pastry chef and then
eventually hired by a restaurant group
in the Washington DC area in 2010 he
opened Bayou bakery coffee bar and
eatery in nearby Arlington Virginia
serving southern influenced specialty
and now there's also his little big
coffee and eatery in Washington he's the
author of two cookbooks both savory and
sweet grill nation and damn good sweet
Vitry New Orleans style desserts
chef David was good morning welcome to
the day morning thank you for having me
tell us about this great table well we
got a good spread for you today we down
at the end we've got our deviled eggs
topped off with a little crawfish
remoulade and the rum you lads a funny
little recipe because it's something we
did as kids where we would squirt
ketchup and mayonnaise directly on the
table this is the lazy man's rub mule on
right here with that love because it's
quick and easy a very impatient chef
right now we've got our good old
cornbread we actually have all the
cornmeal ground for art for us out at
Mount Vernon at the George Washington
grits mill only one in the country that
we that they grind for there you go get
digging into the pimento cheese and we
got the classic barbecue shrimp which
again like gumbo every every house every
restaurants got a little twist on their
version I love putting a lot of fresh
rosemary in it to it that's a nod to my
aunt boo Janice bourgeois who still
lives in Abbeville Louisiana 3 hours
west of New Orleans and she does the
fresh rosemary so I picked that up from
her Thank You Abu and then we got we got
our spinach Madeline and this is
something my sister Tracy would make
every holiday then we got the good old
lemon icebox pie that came from Clancy's
restaurant yeah exactly which a lot of
Tours don't know about but it's a
neighborhood joint and that's what we
call the the the backyard NOLA swinger
this recipe came from a dear friend
fresh grapefruit juice and you can do
bourbon you can do rum really any kind
of a brown spirit so that's fantastic my
friends and family and especially your
aunt boo so when you're 14 you start
developing this love of cooking in her
kitchen that's right but you weren't
sent there too
of cooking you were sent there sorted to
keep you in check that's right my
parents when they kind of threw their
hands up it was it was off to an booze
house in Abbeville because my uncle
passed with many many years issues
raising two girls by herself so she had
a laundry list of chores for me when I
walked on the door cutting the grass you
know doing this doing that things that
the girls wouldn't do Mike one of us one
of those was was giving you in the
kitchen keeping me in the kitchen I was
the only one that had an interest of
what she was doing the girls my cousins
didn't care they in and out get out and
shoot shoot everybody out of the kitchen
for whatever reason I guess I asked the
right questions because she allowed me
in her kitchen to witness what she was
doing and then she's the one that gave
me my first cast-iron pot she's the one
that taught me how to make a roux you
had Cajun influences but you also had
Cuban and father said that's right my
father's father was a practicing
attorney in Havana came to New Orleans
got his law degree at Tulane my
grandmother went back to Cuba and
started a family yeah my dad was there
till 1969 how 59 excuse me they ended up
packing up and moving to New Orleans and
we had family there and so that's kind
of how we got our roots in New Orleans
now Hurricane Katrina came through
destroyed your family's home right you
say you feel as though you lost your
childhood and a connection sure I mean
home is always where mom and dad are so
it was just it represented something for
me that might sort of everything that I
learned and started to really appreciate
about my upbringing was threatened and
so I kind of drowned it in this cookbook
and that's that was the launch of my
first book I brought a local author
Raquel pizzelle who is my co-author she
had never been in New Orleans before she
lives here in Brooklyn and we went down
to Orleans together I got to show her my
city so to be able to show someone for
the first time your city your memories
we went to places because I did zero
research because my city right right so
we go to these places and they were
actually closed and I actually didn't
know that they were closed so she got to
witness firsthand the emotion a grave
and I experienced going back so you put
new points but you put all of your
influences in that book a lot of them in
a way you call yourself an accidental
pastries yeah
fell into it the Windsor Court Hotel was
my first job out of culinary school
German master pastry chef Kurt Ebert
hired me on the spot and day one had
never held a pastry bag in my life and
I'm topping 300 meringue
banquet and I are you sure that wasn't
my wedding 95 so 96 so you know he
showed me once and I said all you have
to do chef has shown me once and I'll do
it the same guy at a time so I think
that I was hungry obviously I was
determined and really my education from
a culinary standpoint started started
there I'm gonna have you sign our dish
oh yeah and ask if you could have this
meal with anyone past or present who
would it be you know I think I lost my
grandfather my Cuban grandfather too
early I was 8 years old so I would love
to be sitting across the table from him
and hearing the stories of his childhood
in Cuba there were members of the Yacht
Club they were sailors they had quite
the life in Cuba prior to the to the
Revolution and I just I want to know
more about where we came from in that
sense I mean I know we all came from
Spain but you know I've done a lot of
research but to watch him eat and chew
and hum whenever he got something that
was just amazing he would hum we could
do that watch and for more on David and
the dish you can head to our website at
CBS this morning calm